foreign
welcome to another wolf language design
review part of our incremental language
development series
and today Conor is sharing his screen
and we are talking about error handling
and Connor take it away
okay
um well right off the bat I'll just warn
everyone I've got a bit of a cough so
apologies for that that shows up
um but so there's no plug in the code
there's a bug in the human though
unfortunately yes okay uh we're talking
about the
machinery for debugging code too so
sorry it doesn't work on humans yet
um okay I'll be the first to sign up
when it does yeah
um right so what we're talking about
today is an effort we've been working on
for for for a while at this point
um which is we're trying to design
essentially a set of uh you know an
error handling framework rule from
language that synthesizes what many uh
wolf and language developers at the
company and and more broadly have
learned about you know Common patterns
of error handling wolf from language in
in kind of large Wolfram language
programs
um so we've had a design effort underway
for a while to kind of synthesize that
experience
um and what we have now is we think you
know we're nearing kind of the first
version of this that we think is ready
for
um experimental usage essentially
um and what we're really keen on is we
think that there's uh
that what we really need here is Real
World experience with this functionality
you know we think we're starting from a
good place because we've already learned
from the experiences of many people from
language developers and what they've
done in their projects but we really
want to validate this design
um and make sure that it's you know it's
rock solid before we proceed through our
normal kind of standardization and
systemization uh procedure
what size of code is this relevant for
like if I'm writing a wfr for example
that is 10 lines long would I care about
this or not
um I think you could use these this
functionality for that it would be
appropriate and certainly it depends a
bit on your style I would certainly use
this functionality in small programs
other people might feel differently
um but it's it's primarily intended for
projects that are on the certainly on
the order of hundreds to you know
thousands tens of thousands of lines
that's what it's kind of it's it's
geared towards so give me a sense here I
mean we've got the confirm and close
stuff
is this intended for larger programs
than confirming clothes is this how does
this relate to confirming clothes
ultimately this will ideally integrate
well with confirm and close
um but it it it's maybe a a super set of
what confirming clothes is trying to do
and it's kind of fundamental mode of
operation is a little different
um confirm and close is unique in that
it's it's a piece of Lexi you know it
primarily does lexical error handling
um and what we're working through here
is something uh based around essentially
exception throwing and catching which is
non-lexical in the general case
okay
okay but so confirming clothes might be
a more lightweight thing
and and so my next question is this kind
of apparatus do we imagine like that you
know an llm might suggest to people you
know given a large piece of code that we
already have
do we expect that one day we're going to
go through and look at existing code we
have and say and have perhaps an llm
suggest you know add these kinds of
annotations to it that kind of the idea
I think that would certainly be a
reasonable thing to try yeah um and
we've done some preliminary tests asking
llms for very short pieces of code and
the results seem seem promising not not
perfect but
um
they perhaps provide a good place to
start
um okay all right jump in how does this
work okay so uh I gave a bit of
background about motivation let me talk
about the actual uh how the framework is
structured so the basic idea is we're
trying to invent as little new as
possible in terms of representation of
Errors so we've had for the last few
years I don't know the exact
introduction date but we've had this
this notion of failure objects in
Wolfram language which had been used
um in newer parts of the system so we're
we're building this new system its core
is this failure object representation we
do not have our own representation of
Errors though we do extend failure by
convention with it with a couple of new
uh
well new things but I'll talk about
those in a second
um the second point is like I mentioned
it's it's very much geared around uh the
kind of the primary functions here are
raise and handle which are analogous to
thrown catches the note here says um but
they're they're they assume that the
payload that is being thrown is a
failure object so they're designed to
make that a very ergonomic you know with
a short piece of code you can throw a
failure you can catch a failure you can
conditionally catch a failure using
pattern matching that kind of thing oh
no sorry Siri wasn't talking to you
um so raise and handle are really the
the core things we talk about here now
this this packaged error tools like I
mentioned it's raise and handle are the
core things but there's a number of
other functions in here that are much
more experimental they're kind of trying
out ideas for what might be useful say
utility functions for error handling so
things like um assertions that throw
instead of issue messages or a version
of replace that that issues a failure if
there's not a rule to handle the value
that was was being replaced
um look okay that that goes into one of
my pet issues there are gazillion
functions which in a sense could have
messages off by default
like replaces a typical example that the
thousands such such situations where
like oh it didn't replace anything well
that could be exactly what you wanted or
it could be an error condition and if we
only had a mechanism for having messages
off by default you can go look up
essentially for a given function oh
these are things that I might worry
about let me handle those things that
would be a reasonable way to do it in my
view rather than peppering kind of
special versions of functions all over
the system because there's so many
functions I mean it's like like I'm
trying to solve an equation the equation
has no Solutions okay that might be
exactly what I want I might have a giant
table of equations and some have
Solutions and some don't or it might be
an error condition
yeah and I I tend to agree I think it
matters a lot on what specific function
you're talking about I think for
something like the notion of assertion
having that be a globally setable
property is is much more viable but for
something like this you may very well
have in the same function the same block
of code one replace is allowed to fall
through and that's perfectly valid but
another replace kind of means something
different I agree but I'm I'm saying if
we had a confirmed quiet type mechanism
that could fish out messages that are
off by default
in other words it is looking for the you
know no replace message from replace
which you would never normally see like
you know without a confirmed quiet of no
replace
it's just like it just goes right by
it's it's takes no time and it does
nothing right yeah but this is a way of
of fishing out things that are fishy so
to speak
you know
by specifically calling them out
I I really believe in this mechanism
because I think that there's just going
to be so many cases where it's like well
that could be a mistake it could be not
a mistake you know I don't know it's
it's kind of a a
um
uh you know a file that turns out to be
zero bytes in size maybe it's an error
maybe it's not but if we had a sort of a
a message off by default that says the
file is zero bytes
then you know you could
you could basically trigger on that if
you wanted to
yeah anyway my two cents worth on that
but that may not be relevant to a lot of
what you want to talk about right well I
think yeah that's not real I mean that
is
it's relevant in one sense but it's
there's a there's a orthogonal part of
this framework that's not far enough
along that we've we've documented yet
but that is that that very closely
mirrors that that notion you were just
talking about of kind of off by default
messages but it brings some structure to
them
um kind of like what we're doing with
with raise and handle
um so that's something we've been
exploring but it's not yet at the point
where we feel comfortable with the
design even to propose experimental
usage
um okay yeah all right so let me I can
get into the example so just basic uh
raise like I said this is all built
around failures so the basic idea is
what Rays does it assembles a failure
object and it throws it
um so it's basic argument structure is
very similar to failure in that it takes
a tag and an association of kind of
metadata
um it additionally has a kind of
convenient Syntax for uh specifying a
message along with that failure
um so format string and some arguments
essentially uh have an example of that
small a small detail but please let's
not use the you know the the camel case
convention for a natural usage message
yeah that's probably be like fmt stir or
something or just fmt yeah
um I'll fix that uh handle is like in
this analogy raise is to throw what
handle is to catch
um so handle takes an expression that
may or may not throw in an a raised
exception and it optionally or sorry and
it takes a second argument that is uh a
pattern that is describes what kinds of
raised failures you want to catch and
the intention here is why don't I just
show an example actually before before I
wax on it let me make a comment though
yep that you know throws tags uh one of
its least
you know we don't like those they have
messy scoping Etc et cetera et cetera a
lot of confirming clothes and its
lexical approach was born out of trying
to avoid the horrors of tag management
yeah so well one of the things that we
kind of the conclusions we came to in
our discussions and reasonable people
may disagree about this was that one of
the difficulties in practice of using
tagged throw and catch is that there's
often I mean first of all just having to
manage that is somewhat cumbersome its
attacks kind of
um but it's it often it doesn't really
afford you the ability to do things like
conditionally catch where there's you
know you may want to catch a raised
failure if it matches a certain pattern
but not otherwise and the and that's
really about the payload the thing that
is thrown not about where it was thrown
from okay
um so we support pattern matching yeah
um
yeah so uh let me let me show an example
but I can get back to that topic um so
basic idea this is probably not going to
be a required thing but for now we do
you have to register a a tag that you're
going to use with raise and handle the
intention here is that this
um
is something that would allow you to
construct error hierarchies essentially
so you have a tag that is somewhat it's
kind of the general error that denotes
any failure in a certain category
um and it may optionally inherit from
other failures so for example you may
have a general class of input output
errors i o errors and you may have a
more specific error type
um say file does not exist error that is
also an i o error
um and that that came out of the
experiences of developers who've worked
on projects with with extremely
complicated error handling where you
often want to be able to model more
granular errors and then handle those
based on you know conditionally at some
higher level saying here's here's how I
handle General i o errors here's how I
handle General database errors and so on
um so this is you know the intention
here is that the system can kind of it
it has a very simple initial usage but
can become more uh featureful if you
want to opt in to say this this you know
more advanced representation of error
tags
um I don't have an example of that here
but but I'm just calling that out of
something you could do so basically yeah
register a tag and then raise an
exception
um now I haven't handled this exception
so this is just an uncaught throw but
you can see that what was thrown was a
failure that was assembled with the the
tag that I specified and the message
that I specified
um
if I want to handle failures uh easy
enough to just handle every failure
don't discriminate that's possible to do
um alternatively you can specify pattern
matching rules that they're just
patterns they match on the payload of
the thing that was thrown so in this
case I'm going to handle Foo errors but
let's say you know it was a bar error
instead that was raised now this passes
through the handle either being an
uncaught exception or something that is
handled at a higher level by a different
Handler
um so that's the basic idea of the
behavior of raise and handle
um okay hold on hold on
so
these tags
okay let's say there's a
I mean I just don't understand how you
manage the tags because this is
dynamically scoped you might have a
giant you know code block of somebody
else's packlet
that you are calling
and your your point is unless they have
an unquote
um you know
an exception with an unquote a tag
unquote in their machinery
you'll never see it
yeah that's your claim yeah and then the
convention we're going to encourage is
that top level functions public
functions that you'd expect to actually
be called will handle their exceptions
they should not have uncaught exceptions
nice certainly hope not right
so okay so then
okay and presumably we will have we
could have
how much how easy is it to do the
analysis of whether that could be an
unquote exception
um it's not too difficult I mean
assuming people don't you know assemble
code on the stack more or less
yeah I mean and the convention we're
encouraging and and uh is that
what you would do is if you have a top
level function you know here represented
just by a function that's that's capital
camel case
you would tend to write something along
these lines where you're using the
operator form of handle that's wrapped
around the body of your function and
consequently encompasses both that
function and all other in kind of
internal functions in your package so
nothing could really get past this
um
so that's a sub-value form of handle
the once actually can't handle which is
which which is an operator form so to
speak
that is equivalent to handle of get two
pulse comma blank failure correct yeah
and it's it's specifically designed to
be very ergonomic in this use case
um where you want to Veer very clearly
see when you're I mean because we have
nothing like that with throw that's a
that's a good reason for handle to even
exist
is the operator form
yeah so sandal not hold anything
uh how how can this work
um handle handles
pure function which is holding that's
the only way to make it work currently
yeah if you do I mean this is yeah
well
but it's just returning a function with
attribute hold first
I see
well that's kind of ugly that's
something we'd want to fix
I don't disagree you're going to need
one day we're going to need some values
able to deal with attributes
yeah we're gonna need this you know
that's an evaluated change
okay
um
yeah so that's that's the basic example
and I and I kind of can talk through
this example I won't go into too much
detail but this is how it's imagined you
would use this in general
um
I've written it this way with this kind
of body function being separated from
the definition just so that I can
explain this alternative but I'll get
back to this in a second
um but the general idea is okay so what
does the function do well it reads a
file so okay it calls out to a function
called read file which itself can raise
failures
um so if you have a look at the
definition of read file yeah it checks
things says Hey file doesn't exist
you've got you know it attaches any
relevant attributes is metadata in The
Association Along with the descriptive
text
um does its thing now crucially you'll
notice that read file does not handle
its exceptions it does not have that
handle underscore failure yeah
um so that means and this is this is
where we would compare to confirm and
close this means that we don't have to
if this was a confirm and close based
project you would have an enclose here
and some code that kind of throws the
failure or you know Returns the failure
here and at this call site you would
again you need another copy of confirm
confirming the return value of this
function so using this non-lexical
raise and handle approach we don't need
to have intermediate confirms just
propagating errors up the stack which in
a large project it's kind of a lot of
line noise where you just yeah
so that's the idea anyway this function
goes through whatever splits the
contents it does some validation of the
entries in the file so it has this
internal error entry thing gives you
some contextual information about hey
it's this line on which the error in
your file appears
um
does its thing so let's see what
actually calling this function
sorry what are the arguments to raise
so the argument is to handle
where's the one argument form handle
that's zero
okay
and raise
raises that exception
so there's no
I see it's a pure side effecty thing
what does raise return
it doesn't because it it it's control
flow diverges it's it's like throw it
doesn't return anything
I see so whenever you hit arrays
you're propagating outwards like throw
correct
okay
um
it helps just what is the definition of
this you can see it's it's definition at
least in the common cases it's pretty
simple it's just a throw of this other
helper
okay
okay uh so just getting back to the
example because this shows off a couple
of piece that functionality pieces
um let me make sure actually I've
I mean technically throw returns null
but you'll you'll never actually see
that
right yeah so we've got things in the
kernel working correctly but uh yeah
um so let's let's look at a little
example let's let's as opposed to
from early pre-version one code
the the I don't know that's still around
the dollar dollar luxury yacht that's
the return thing when didn't know what
to return
that was uh
a fine contribution from an early
programmer
um
okay
um so let's just walk through so this is
a I've just made a file that's valid so
get tuples works as we expect let's have
a look if we give it you know does not
exist.txt
we get our error file doesn't exist tag
useful metadata about well what what was
the object I see what when a file does
not exist that was a file path that was
given as a sock
and so the first thing is a tag in the
Rays
and that's a tag you registered somehow
although you didn't really need to do
that yeah and we'll probably remove that
requirement ultimately
because in the common case you don't I
mean it's kind of like typing as in uh
it's you know it the as you add
bureaucracy you confirm the program I
was paying attention and didn't make a
typo for example
yeah there are Arguments for keeping it
um certainly
well I mean the thing is there's partly
an IDE ux type question of whether you
know like for example you know we could
perfectly well in the code assistance
system tag
whether
you know like let's say there was a typo
in somebody's tag
the question is can we can we readily
tag that so to speak we readily indicate
that
and if the answer is yes I don't think
it's terribly important to have these
things where you're sort of forced to
sort of enroll in the bureaucracy
okay
and I think there's a good chance and
and I really I don't want to open this
can of worms because this gets
complicated very fast but some people
here may have noticed that one of the
the disadvantages of the way this is
structured is
uh if it encourages you to write these
raw strings in here that makes
localization much more difficult right
so one of the things that and I have a
note about this this hasn't been
documented but you can just do right now
there's no reason you can't write this
and this is you know if you have a
system where you know this thing
evaluates to the string right now yes
evaluation not a desirable feature but
it is
um
but I mean we could we have to intercept
that evaluation and because we we had a
convention back from version one of you
know symbol colon column name message
Name colon colon language right yeah
yeah which I assume we use in actuality
yep
yeah
but I don't understand how this would
work unless unless Reyes is holding that
second argument well the the idea is
that this I mean this is not worked
through which is why I'm saying I'm kind
of wanting to keep the lid on this can
of worms whether this would
issue a message or not because if it
doesn't need to issue a message and
you're essentially purely just using
this for the localization or message
lookup functionality you don't really
care about keeping it held you just want
the string contents of the message
um if you do want this to issue issue a
message as well
that's a different scenario that we'd
have to work through that's actually
reasonable behavior for raise
um okay I just want to point out as a
stop Gap measure it's using our existing
localization system which may be
perfectly reasonable this works
um but we do tentatively have
thinking around if you want to be able
to write a you know a readable error
message here we would very much want to
have linting to check that this string
exists in your localization lookup
you know key value database where
however that ends up being implemented
this is something that's not we've not
worked through at all but well I mean
the other possibility is
yeah you see yeah we we want to be able
to gosh I mean that seems like a tool
that needs to be able to go through a
piece of code okay here's a way to think
about this you write a piece of code you
interactively write it it's very fast
you don't have a lot of error handling
stuff in it because you're just trying
to see what it basically works
then you're going back and robustifying
the code
then you might be going back and trying
to do things like make the code
localizable
so if we provided the right tooling the
tooling actually worked to go through
and say let me take my quickly written
piece of code and let me go and make it
more robust
and give me suggestions for how to do
that oh you put an arrays you put in a
handle you do this you do that
that to me would be a good workflow
because that's what a lot of people I
mean some people know their writing code
for the ages
right from the outset
okay but many times in many usage
patterns you initially are just trying
to explore something and get something
to work
and then you might come back and say
okay now I want to make it into WR now I
want to make it into a more robust thing
that I'm going to use for the future and
then you want to put an error handling
and localization and so on
as a post-talk kind of thing as opposed
to I'm doing this from the beginning I'm
going to sign up for the giant
bureaucracy from the start
yeah
so I I don't know is this is this
plan
I mean have we thought at all about what
that looks like from ux point of view to
take a piece of code
and say
you know I mean it probably is a toolbar
type thing and say uh scan this notebook
for example for things where it's
probably going to be Beyond The Notebook
it's going to be a full project and an
IDE
um you know scan this for places where
one might add error handling capability
we've not done
much more than kind of just very general
thinking about do we think this would be
something that for example an llm would
have a relatively easy time writing and
we have done tests around if you give an
llm say the usage messages of each of
these functions and then ask it write a
program and I've done this write a
program that does you know essentially
some basic file processing using these
error handling functionality it makes
reasonable suggestions it wasn't perfect
but but it it you know it got it got
like a useful degree of the way there
like ah I see now okay so that's a
possible error condition I should handle
and the human can kind of fix up
whatever minor mistake they all have
made
um whether you know the overall workflow
exactly what level of suggestions the LM
should be making
you know what what at what the
appropriate moment to invoke the tooling
is that's not something that I I think I
have a clear idea about what the ux
should be yet okay but but to make a
different point
I mean one of the things about error
handling so I mean the overarching
feature of error handling is there's a
main code path for a piece of code
which the programmer thought about
then they're all the things that might
go wrong most of which the programmer
didn't think about
and to me a lot of error handling is how
much can we automate the secondary code
path of the thing that the programmer
didn't think about so to speak
yeah
um
and and also to what extent do we want
you know as we've talked about before
there are errors
where
you know you're doing exploratory data
science and something goes wrong and
some piece of data is absent or whatever
else and it's going to spray some
garbage in what you're doing but it's
okay you still can see your way through
the garbage
another case is you're trying to decide
whether to you know launch a rocket or
not or whatever and you really want it
to be the case that if anything went
wrong you flag it as something went
wrong you know
you know stop
right and it's a question of where how
one can tell
yeah which of these
right so they're you know we've talked
about this endlessly over the course of
Decades of you know how to define Banks
of errors that are critical errors
versus you might like to know that type
errors and so on
yeah is this is that relevant to what
we're talking about here
it's relevant to the broader question of
error handling it's less relevant to
specifically what we're I think bringing
to this discussion today
um which is again the the use case that
we're primarily keeping in mind is for
developers who were putting a reasonable
amount of trust in to make a good faith
attempt to handle errors proactively you
know they're going to think about the
code they're writing and try to handle
errors I.E us you know us who are
working on the language every day and
writing kind of professional software in
it
um
so that that's why we haven't done a lot
of thinking about for you know how do we
make this work really well as a broader
ux question error handling in general
for
all right okay I understand
okay onward
okay uh let me see where did I okay so I
give a basic example of say file doesn't
exist now let me show what it looks like
if there's a invalid entry in the file
we get a message like this telling us
hey line three you've got a problem yeah
um it looks simple and obvious and makes
sense all right so where does it where
do things go horrible
uh well let me let me have one other
example on this theme so I mentioned I
have these two variants of git tuples
this other variant uses this wrap raised
function which I'm not going to explain
I'm just going to show
um and if I call this again what rap
raised has done is it's taken that
original error and made it a just a
member of a more general error which is
ideally more useful at the level of
context that the user has when they're
calling this function which is hey I
passed in a file and the error it
mentions hey there's some problem with
my file affect the argument is
yeah
so rap Rays is itself an operator form
um and it's essentially the same
argument structure as raise itself but
it
it catches any exception and it
annotates the Rays as as the Rays comes
through it annotates it with some other
information about the context in which
it lives exactly
yeah so I yeah and I've converted a few
projects to using these new functions
this has been I found tremendously
useful in practice that the name could
clearly be improved but being able to at
you know the level of the the kind of
definition of a function where you've
often got really good high level context
actually put that context in errors that
are coming from lower levels where it'd
be cumbersome to pass that idea I mean
we've never had this idea of on in
transit a throw in transit gets
annotated
yeah
so what what is this rep raised again
like I guess I missed something in this
discussion
let me try and explain it the
you have a low level raise okay
somewhere deep in your code
it knew that the thing that actually
happened deep in your code was the list
was of length zero okay but then what
you really want to know is that happened
inside this higher level function
what you really want to know is the the
you know the Walker walked off the cliff
so to speak but that's not known down at
the low level but you can then put at
the level of the of the Walker you can
put a wrap raised which says if you see
this I I would get I don't know is it is
it any
unhandled
in this in this invocation it's any
unhandled thing and that's one of the
sticking points of the design of this
function is how to make it also
appropriately conditional whether it
should have its own pattern matching
logic or not but anyway but the point
peritized purposes is as it comes out it
knows that that zero length list or
whatever is part of the Walker function
which it didn't know down the low levels
and so it wraps the message that's
coming out to say oh this is a walker
thing
does that make sense at I okay so it's
it's sort of like uh our proverbial
message reissuing
function that we would want that we want
to have
well yes
I didn't know we wanted a message
reassuring function
yeah but yeah I've not heard of it but
it sounds similar yeah
well there is obviously a difference
because messages are they do not divert
the control flow and here we are dealing
with the uh diverted control flow
through exceptions and so yeah but in
that sense it's not divert the control
flow this is just adding it's just you
know the things going by and it's
tagging it it's adding an additional tag
to the thing that's racing by being
thrown yeah this one doesn't divert but
it deals with the result of this
diversion yes
yeah and if it helps you can see the
definition of this is actually pretty
simple it just it returns an op the
operator form of handle that catches a
failure
uses this rap failure thing to construct
a new failure and then re-raises it so
it's exactly what you might expect catch
change the name relay is popping into my
head
relay okay maybe it's part of the name
no I'll note that down it can have a
better name I mean right let's not get
derail by the name I just had that idea
so maybe jot it down for brainstorming
foreign
there's a relay throw right you catch
one person's throw and you throw it to
the next person oh okay right you know
yeah so okay yeah but you don't sign the
ball on the way which is what this is
doing right but you might put different
spin on it
right I don't know it's like it's like
the game of telephone or something
except you're intentionally distorting
the message
um
yeah
well well yeah obviously naming of all
these is going to be an exercise of its
own
um this was really the main example I
wanted to get through to illustrate kind
of how these things are used the
conventions we're trying to form around
them
um I do have a couple there are some
other things uh you know this is there's
a lot of functions in here
um one again that I think is a
particular use again particularly in
these projects where you're trying to be
relatively strict in your code is this
set fall through error function and all
this is is it just it takes a symbol as
an argument and it sets a down value on
that symbol you know a triple underscore
down value that catches anything else so
it's it's a way to annotate a symbol as
being like this is a symbol that you
must call with correct arguments
um that's a good idea I mean that's the
thing where there's a lot of silly messy
code that tries to deal with that case
yeah and I should be clear
that's a terrible name yeah
um a lot of these come from like
different generations of thinking about
the naming convention that haven't been
cleaned up yet I mean I kind of I I
don't understand why you wouldn't be
able to give a message there a custom
message for what to do in that case
you definitely should be able to yeah
which actually I don't know if I have a
note about that but I'm certainly to
write it down
okay
yeah you know I wonder how complicated
that function would end up getting like
I oh I mean it's it's probably that is
the useful case it's just if nothing
matched
that's the problem
oh yeah and it should be said
go ahead let me say real quick it should
be said that you know the use cases in
which cell fall through error are useful
are
um
it is not something we would ever intend
a end user to see like as we've done our
job we've got a bug in our code if an
end user ever actually sees this but it
does mean that they get a very clear
like if they if they contact you know
our bug report report email address we
can see very precisely ah that so
somehow somewhere this function was
called with incorrect arguments instead
of being some kind of huge message spew
that fails inelegantly and is harder to
die yeah but I I think for wfrs in most
cases you just want to add this period
you know you can't be bothered to write
all the pattern cases and you just stick
it at the end
yeah and for what it's worth in
databases and other projects uh we have
hundreds of these statements sprinkled
after pretty much each internal function
the name for this function we used was
different but the idea was exactly what
is it
we had something like DB def error
something like that but this was like uh
very specific to you okay so that's fine
that's specific to that project yeah but
the the idea the general thing was
different was the same and I have to say
that this I this alone was responsible
for catching maybe 80 or 90 of our bugs
early
because typically the bugs that occurred
from regressions or elsewhere in
internal functions they immediately
became obvious they didn't generate this
you know accumulation of dispute error
messages because it got caught within
that one function exactly
which is there's a point there about
like you asked earlier Stephen like when
somebody's quick and dirty writing a
piece of functionality and they're not
really going to add error handling if
there's any one function that I would
definitely use in even in that initial
prototyping stage where I just try to
get something working quick on the happy
path it would be this one
um it would almost be by default added
when wfrs are packaged up
perhaps it almost might be the case that
you ask people you know there might be
some heuristic based on the code and
then you basically ask people do you
want to make sure it only works in these
cases if yes check here and it'll
automatically add that definition I
think for debugging purposes though an
uncut throw is a very very bad thing
it's difficult to deal with because you
get no stack Trace if there's no
surrounding handle that will actually
catch one of these it should probably
issue a message at the time that it
generates the throw
so that way you can actually get a stack
Trace from where things went wrong
in fact actually a good point there
perhaps we should have a variant of this
that doesn't throw on fall through it
just makes the function return a failure
um
but also we do have stack traces in the
works that will be automatically added
at the Taiwan arrays actually throws an
exception can we just add it to throw
right and the question well I mean the
question is since given Stephen's
suggestions about wfrs I mean do we want
wfrs to be throwing uncut exceptions we
don't
whenever they're called with a wrong
number of arguments which is oh in that
particular case we want it to error out
at the level of that one function rather
that I mean this is the this is again
this whole question about what's the
level of of stoppage if something goes
wrong
like for wfr the typical wfr if
something goes wrong it's just well the
function should return unevaluated over
the message
okay but it shouldn't stop the world
but there are other cases
where we have no choice
you know that that types of sort of
fatal errors where you've got to stop
everything
yeah and also uh set fall through
predominantly will be used in like 95 of
cases it's useful for interim function
but if we want to have exhaustive uh you
know exhaustive definition that caches
errors also for the end user function we
may have either a different mode of
operation for supple through or Define
another function that basically works
for the uh user-facing functions
functions to do I mean in this case you
want it to raise an exception yeah and
exit basically
otherwise it could simply return a
failure or return an evaluated with a
message or whatever mode of operation we
we see fit for that particular function
yeah fine I mean that then what would be
useful would be
which I like very much
you know just like you can call set
attributes on a function and specify you
know set attributes hold all or whatever
else
to be able to say and I think we've
talked about this before but this is a
clearer version of this to be able to
say about this function okay we got a
bunch of definitions now add in
something which of all definitions fail
the function returns unevaluated
I guess that happens by default but
maybe returns unevaluated with a message
right normally if all the definitions
fail
I mean this is the problem the problem
is
sometimes you are a definition fired
from a pattern matching point of view
you're deep inside the function you
realize something is horribly wrong and
you just want it in fact to return
unevaluated how do we do that
so like the function is B the down value
has begun executing right yeah and now
you find out something is horribly raw
as you check the audio structure or
something like this typically what
people do we use the local variables
computed inside with or something and
then if those values of those variables
are not what we like then uh there is a
conditional down value that is
considered not matched by evaluator even
though it already started drawing
because it was in the slash semi right
yes yeah yeah right see in version point
nine
long ago
we had a whole collection of mechanisms
for this
which unfortunately kind of crumbled at
the last minute in other words there was
a mechanism where there was a special
value that could be returned that means
think of this as not having matched
and another value that could be returned
that meant uh you know we now know
nothing could match this or nothing
should be deemed to match
does that make sense I'm curious what
the names for those were
they would Jala
I think they were things like dollar
failed actually and and um uh we can
look it up I'm not sure it's been that's
36 years ago yeah but I was just curious
no no that would be inspirational
they weren't bad names
they weren't bad but the problem was and
I I don't remember what crumbled at the
end
I think go ahead well I was just gonna
Hazard a guess I mean they seem a kind
of thing that like handling a value like
that could almost be poisonous if you're
doing it even mildly complicated
terminated evaluation stuff which which
we just changed now you know so many
years later
uh but I think it's worth looking at
this again because I think that that
idea of you're deep inside the down
value you find out something is wrong
you want to say return
and now we've got this failure construct
but we have you know we it's like
quoting the quote you'll never win in
the end whatever it is we return it's
going to be something fun here and it's
going to be somewhat poisonous
but but it's just a convention and we
have to say if it returns this thing
that says you know fail now or something
okay if you want to return fail now from
a function well it's not going to work
well
yeah but I think our general experience
has been that those quoting the quote
situations
uh
mostly don't work too badly
mostly that nothing too horrifying
happens in practice
yeah
and if it is if there is a situation
where you can't just can't use that
magic thing you can always restructure
the code to be a bit you know handle it
a bit more robustly in that uncommon
situation yeah right but I do think that
this you know return unevaluated if the
look if if the goal is return a failure
object it's easier than returning
unevaluated because you say return the
failure object
we are actually trying to go to that
mode from returning unevaluated for a
number of reasons whenever is possible
well that's an interesting philosophical
change again
well Lena is saying that return failure
rather than returning unevaluated yeah
we're trying to we are trying to uh to
do that more because returning
unevaluated uh as I understand
historically it came from more computer
algebra related contexts but in many
cases when you're returning a failure
you both can give more information about
what went wrong and also it's an
Ambiguously a failure so you don't have
to necessarily accompany it with a
message or then try to determine later
whether it was a fail or whether it was
intended to return unevalid
okay but look the counter argument is
this the number one reason for returning
unevaluated is the system didn't know
what to do with something but you might
yes but but the thing is that uh in a
number of cases which are more kind of
programming in nature then
transformational
yeah yes
yeah I agree in in the programming cases
failure is better than returning
unevaluated yeah evaluated in a
transformation you know if everything is
very symbolic
then returning unevaluation makes more
sense absolutely
but also for their handling and for
programming cases and the other aspect
of that why it is important often to
return a failure is that we want to uh
to basically quit as early as possible
with an error so the longer we wait
until error is diagnosed the worse it is
in terms of the you know the analysis of
what went wrong
well and you might careen off into you
know burning up all your memory and
blowing the computer up
exactly
okay
well that's a good argument I mean that
look both cases are useful and having a
nice clean support for both cases seems
worthwhile
okay any what else do we want to cover
here Connor
um nothing specific I think that was we
wanted to give you a good sense of
since you've chosen that to be very
explicit I'm going to be very explicit
right so this is a packlet that
currently lives in the layout but there
is also a version of it uh in the
packlet repository which is the page on
the right that uh
uh Conor is displaying their
um so it's sort of pseudo documented as
an experimental thing in the packlet
repo
um since you expressed some hesitation
about this when we presented that same
idea to you for the diff tools packlet
although that's something that's going
to be at least initially going to be
only on the packlet repo not in the
layout this is something that is both in
the layout and on the plaque repo which
is you want to you are asking 414 should
this be documented
well it's well it's should it be
semi-documented in the sense that it's
on the packlet repo and people can look
there if they want to try this out
I think we should try to see if we can
actually make it documented documented
as an experimental feature
well still on that may destroy the uh
purpose of this current stage of trying
to use it in large projects because the
requirement to try and to document it
will require us to do full fledged
design review and figure out all things
as much as we can to not cause backward
incompatibilities later and at this
stage we're simply not ready for that at
least that's our collection that's the
way it is so then the question of
whether it's in the layout or not seems
kind of moot because it's kind of you
know nobody's even going to know about
it except from packlet repository
exactly
so what's your question it's all right
well we suggested that you know we get
div tools into the packlet repo as a as
a
uh you know as sort of a staging ground
for eventual inclusion and you expressed
a great deal of hesitation about that
and since this is now something that's
actually already in the packlet repo
okay look my hesitation about these
things is
you know the creep of it wasn't design
reviewed it's in the packet repository
lots of people are using it oh we should
just put it in as it is without further
design review because it's been there
for a long time or because lots of
people are using it and it's kind of a
design review avoidance strategy and
that I'm not happy with
but so long as we recognize that it's in
the packet repository people are using
it from the packet repository the
version that goes into the system will
be will not May will be incompatible
yes which
which you know I think I think will also
be true of the diff tools packlet
because right if nothing else we will be
moving things from the packlet repo
context to system right when when it
eventually migrates
which hopefully will be not too long for
both of these
right
right then the question becomes do you
update the packlet the packet repo to be
consistent I think you blow it away I
think you basically say you can use this
old thing if you want to but it's Legacy
and the real thing is the thing in the
system yeah I think you make those
choices per case but a lot of times they
don't make sense to blow it away right I
mean you might want to update the
packlet well I guess the question is can
you make that
if you could use the packlet repo to
no no I guess if you wanted to make this
functionality available to older
versions you would have to release it
via the packlet server and blow away
what's in the packlet repo right if you
wanted like if difficult moves into
system but you want to give ex you know
allow users of previous versions access
to that the nude blow away what's in the
packlet repo and put a version on the
packlet server for people to
new system symbols in the packlet repo
oh okay yeah search me I didn't
understand that I to me if
look somebody hopefully we have good
enough tooling that somebody if they use
this in that program that program knows
that this is the version 13.3
you know raise function
from the Packer Repository
and if subsequently there is a system
raise function it will just not be the
same function
yeah
right so with the llm things right those
sort of started out in the packlet repo
and now they're in system but we we're
still sort of making that functionality
available to previous versions
via the packlet repo and so the question
is you know what if we wanted to do
something like that
but it's going to be a case-by-case sort
of exactly right and just like you know
we make Cloud object
updates available for five-year-old
versions right so you know it's just
going to be sort of on the case by case
exactly how we want to do this but I
think we all agree that
you know once this there's the system
version that's the canonical version
that supersedes anything that may or may
not have been in the packlet repo
100 yeah I mean we'd slap a giant label
I think we would want to leave it there
for anyone who might be using it in
older versions yeah of course it might
be an existing code yeah but we'd slap a
giant label on the one in the Packer
repository this has been superseded by X
Y and Z functionality and we'll find out
and we already do that in the function
repository we have that label ready to
go right yeah and and probably put you
know a Max version in the packlet itself
so it won't load in any newer version
and cause issues
I don't think we want to do that we
would they should be able to exist
simultaneously in case you do have
something that's depending on the old
context
yeah
okay
correct yeah
yeah looks good this is nice and simple
well done Connor and everybody working
on this
um
it looks easy at the end
[Music]
thank you oh yeah it was certainly a
massive team effort and many of the
people here to thank for many of the
crucial design aspects so
Kudos all around looking good all right
see you all soon bye for now thank you